whoo this is Matt Poole seamonkey Mike
Hill I mean it was my grenade that came
out of my grenade launcher that blew
that dudes ass hole through his [ __ ]
mouth I had him all I saw as I looked
down you were just doing that weird warm
up there with those big old flesh
paddles of yours hey if you [ __ ] look
at me like that Phelps okay I can Phelps
pace all [ __ ] day long okay you have
serious issues yeah well I'm not trying
to call you out here in the middle of
the battlezone
but you don't know how to lose and
that's an issue man it's a big issue
we're on the same team you know that Oh
are we are we Michael because to me when
I'm on a team with someone and someone
does something super [ __ ] dope like
blow up a bunch of astronauts there's
like a high five we're like a [ __ ]
way to go teammate they just said I'm
just getting this from you just a
[ __ ] here's the [ __ ] [ __ ] face a
face you make we need to take a [ __ ]
that's not teammate talk folks okay and
if that's how you're gonna treat me then
guess what man maybe I don't want to
[ __ ] be your team okay so take your
pistols and backstroke the [ __ ] out of
here I'm sick of the attitude you know
what you're lucky that I did not frag
your ass actually I wish that I would
have but everyone on the internet see
you lose people would love that
hashtag frag Phelps with a pH he [ __ ]
hilarious man she would go venereal I
think you mean viral no I mean venereal
she does [ __ ] infectious is sexual
can we just focus on the game you have
no idea what you're doing
Phelps I'm not playing I will blast this
grenade right in your [ __ ] nut sack